pascal thévenot 50 ans et le député
sortant de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines un mandat d'un an seulement en
mars 2016 il est élu avec plus de 72%
après la démission de valérie pécresse
je tire un bilan plutôt positif j'ai eu
aussi un peu de chance c'est que je suis
arrivé directement au mieux vaut de la
loi sur le travail qui était donc pour
mon passé de chef d'entreprise et
j'étais aussi investi et dans le monde
syndical patronal
donc c'est un monde que je connais
parfaitement j'ai pu totalement
m'investir dès le départ et même
christian jacob avait fait confiance
pour participer à des auditions qui
permettait de deux mètres d'alimenter la
loi de faire des amendements en 2008 il
fait partie de la majorité municipale de
vélizy-villacoublay commune dont il est
élu maire en 2014
un territoire auquel il est très attaché
j'ai fait mes études à versailles j'ai
fait ensuite des études supérieures à
saclay où j'étais aussi investi dans le
monde dans le monde associatif
et je pense que c'est une envie qu'on
doit avoir et les gens lors que le
ressentent ses axes de campagne la
sécurité la politique familiale le
logement l'emploi mais aussi
l'apprentissage
si on veut relancer l'apprentissage
pourquoi un apprenti très bon moins bien
lotis qu'un ingénieur les moineaux ce
qu'on propose c'est que l'apprentissage
les écoles d'apprentissage soit financée
par l'état et pour ça c'est un peu près
un milliard cinq dont il suffit de
supprimer tous les emplois aidés qui
sont des artifices de statistiques pour
mettre le paquet sur l'apprentissage 16
autres candidats se présentent aux
élections législatives le 11 juin
prochain pascal thévenot affrontera
notamment jean noël barrot candidat de
la république en marche et yasmine
belmadi représentant du front national